اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما نناقش كالعاده ابرز ملفات
اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء هل ينجح بوتين
في انهاء قطيعه تركيه سوريه اندمت لاكثر
من 11 عاما وهل هي مصالحه فقط ام تحالف
جديد ضد اطراف اخرى في ملفنا الثاني لماذا
يستخدم بوتين مرتزقه فاجنر اوكرانيا
لقدرته على حسن المعركه امل ان انتهاكاتها
لن تتحمل دوله روسيه عواقبها القانونيه
وفي ملفنا الثالث الجنيه المصري يفقد نصف
قيمته في اقل من عام هل التعويم كنا ضروره
هل هي سياسه مؤلمه فقط ام ان لها جوانب
اقتصاديه او ايجابيه للاقتصاده
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل بعد احد عشره عاما
من القطيعه مسار خريطه الاتصال بين انقره
ودمشق بواسطه الروسيه ارتسمت معالمه
وطريقه تطبيع العلاقات بتواضحه حيث تسعى
روسيا هذه المره للاعبي دوري قيادي في
حلحله الازمه السوريه التركيه وفي تهيئه
الظروف التي تسمح بلقاء الرئيس اردوغان
بنظره السوري بشار الاسد
عن اجتماع المرتقبا بين وزراء خارجيه
تركيا وسوريا وروسيا هذا الشهر وربما قبل
منتصف الاسبوع المقبل حيث رجع حتى ان هذا
الاجتماع قد يعقد اما قبل لقاء وزير
الخارجيه التركي
او من بعده في اشاره ثانيه لان الهدف من
هذا اللقاء هو اعاده العلاقات التركيه
السوريه الى مسارها الصحيحه بعد اتهامه
طويله بين اردوغان وبشار الاسد كما
ستكونوا اولويه هذه الاجتماعات ازمه
اللاجئين والتنظيمات الارهابيه حيث سيحاول
كل طرف فرض بعض الشروط تركيا تريد التخلص
من وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في حين
سوريا ستطالب بتصفيه داعش وفق مراقبين فان
الاكراد قد يدفعون ثمن هذا التقارب بين
انقره وادي دمشق خصوصا وانا انقر تعتبر
وحدات الشعب الكرديه منظمتان ارهابيه
مرتبطه بحزب العمال الكردستاني
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من اسطنبول
الدكتور بكيره توجان مدير ومحد اسطنبول
للفكر اهلا بك دكتور ومن دمشق عبد الحميد
توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم
من دمشق معك يا استاذ عبد الحميد استاذ
عبد الحميد نشير فقط الى ان هذا اللقاء
المرتقب على مستوى وزراء الخارجي صديقه
كذلك لقاء ثلاثي بين وزراء دفاع البلدان
الثلاثه سوريا تركيا وايه روسيا ولكن
يقولوا البعض بان ترتيب لقاء اخر في مستوى
عالي همم الاكيد بان صديقه اتفاق ماء
سابقته صفقه ماء ما مفهوم سوريا لهذا
التقارب في هذه الفتره بالتحديد
مساء الخير لك لما والضيفك الكريم والساده
المشاهدين اعتقد بان الاشارات التي
والمواقف بالاحرى التي صدرت عن الجانب
التركي اييي وعلى المستوى الدبلوماسيه على
لسان وزير الخارجيه تركي مولود شاويش
اوغلو ااه قطعت الشك باليقين بان لقاء ان
الدبلوماسيه سينقد
وسيجتمع هو نظيره السوري وكذلك وجود
الروسي وحتى انه تحدث عن ان مسك قد تكون
خيارا جغرافيا وربما عواصم اخرى وبالتالي
اعتقد بان الحديث الذي اتى به وزير
الخارجيه التركي يؤكد بان العمليه عمليه
التفاهمات قائمه وخصوصا اذا معنى نظرنا
الى اللقاء الثلاثي الذي جمع وزيريه
الدفاع بوجود الوزير الروسي ايضا في موسكو
قبل همم
والذي يسيطر عنه بيان نعم الذي صدر عنه
بيان واضح يقول بان الجانبين كانها اجريها
بنائه وحتى موقف السوري كان في هذه المره
اصدر بيان الرسميه واكد بان المباحثات
بنائه وانه تم الاتفاق على عدد من النقاط
التي لابد من بحثها وتعدث وزير الدفاع
التركي عن تشكيل لجان لتتمت هذه القضايا
ذات الاهتمام المشترك وذات القلق المشترك
في الجانب التركي تحدث عن هواجس امنيه
يمثلها جسدها
وكثراع لحزب العمال الكردستاني المصنف
ارهابيا لدى تركيا وسوريا تحدثت ايضا عن
بعض المطالب التي يمكن ان تكون قواعد
لبناء ثقه مع تركيا اعتقد ان الصفقه التي
تسالينها عنها
هي عباره عن تفاهمات اوليه يمكن البناء
عليها من خلال خلق التي توازن بين
الجانبين برعايه الروسيه وبرغبه المشتركه
اولا واخيرا بين تركيا وبين سوريا هذه
الرغبه تلاقت عندها المصالح عندها الماء
الرغبات المطالب وكذلك همم الجانبان
السوري والتركي ماذا يعتقدان بانه هموم كل
طرف لابد من همم
الاخذها بعين الاعتبار وبالتالي الانطلاق
الى نقاط متقدمه في العمل الدبلوماسي وزير
الخارجيه التركي يقول بان هذا اللقاء
سيبهد لقاء القمه بعد ان تتبلور كثير من
اتفاقات والقضايا التي يجب ان تسبق لقاء
القمه المرتقب او المجمع بين الرئيسين
السوري والتركي لاحقا
تم الحديث عنه وكانت هناك حتى تسريبات بان
همم روسيا قد تحضر لي هكذا لقاء ولكن
دكتور بكير خلينا ندخل في تفاصيل نقاط
الالتقاء ونقاط همم التباعد او الاختلاف
بين الجانبين البعض يقول بان هذه المرحله
التقارب هو في مصلحه تركيا بدرجه اولى
ولكن فيما يخص مثلا منطقه شمال سوريا في
ما يخص تواجد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه همم
كيف ترتب او ما نقاط في لن تحد عنها تركيا
فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
تحياتي مساء الخير
والساده المشاهدين
طبيعي اولا لابد الاشاره الى همم نقطه
هامه اليوم ذكرها الناطق باسم همم الحزب
العداله والتنميه الحزب الحاكم في تركيا
قبل ساعات بان هناك سمه التقارب بين تركيا
وسوريا
واشار الى نقطتين هامه وهي التي ذكرتيها
قبل قليل شمال سوريا وخاصه النقطه بالنسبه
لتركيا والتي مهمه جدا هي تواجد حزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي الوحدات الشعبيه التي
هي جزء من حزب العمال الكردستاني
والنقطه الثانيه ايضا همم اللاجئين
السوريين علما علما بان اريد ان ازيد نقطه
على هذه التصريحات بالنسبه للاجئين
السوريين لو لو فرضا همم
سوريا قالت نعم اعتبارا من هذا اليوم او
غدا او بعد شهر
نحن على استعداد لاستقبال هؤلاء اللاجئين
وبدون شروط ليس من الامر ارسال حل هذه
المشكله بهذه السهوله وبهذه السرعه
لاسباب عديده
داخليه وخارجيه بالنسبه لتركيا وايضا
بنسبه لسوريا داخليه وخارجيه
هي تطلب من الجانب السوري ان تكون هناك
خطه محكمه وان تكون هناك همم ضمنات امنيه
لما يقرب عن الاربعه ملايين سوريا يعني
تقريبا ثلاث ملايين و500,000 سوري فداخل
تركي هل همم خليني اسال الاستاذ توفيق في
هذا الموضوع هل يمكن ان تقدم استاذ توفيق
سوريا من جهاتها ضمن الجنابه التركي حتى
يتم او تتم حالته هذا الموضوع
اعتقد انه ليس بعيدا ان انا طالما ان
الرغبه الرغبه واضحه والاراده السياسيه
لدى الطرف التركي
مترجم على ارض الواقع اعتقد ان مثل هذه
العناوين مساله الضمانات لعوده اللاجئين
ماذا ستكون ستكون ان عودتهم وفق القضائيه
القوانين الناظمه بذلك من
اراد العوده الى دياره وارضه فلا بد من
توفير المناخ والبيئه والبنيه التي يمكن
ان يعود اليها صاحب الارض او صاحب الدار
وهؤلاء العداد البلايين ولكن اعتقد بانه
ايضا من المستحيل ليس من الصعب فقط من
المستحيل ان تقدم اي دوله سوريه وغيرها
ضمانات ل 3 اي نصف مليون ناجي الا في بند
ربما يكون بند سياسي ضمن اتفاقيه سياسيه
وقد تكون سوريا وتركيا وروسيا هما اهم
المثلث الذي يمكن ان يرعى مثل هذه العوده
بعد التفاهمات والاتفاقات المزرعه التي
يمكن ان تصل اليها الاطراف الثنائيه تركيه
وسوريه برعايه الروسيه لذلك يعتقد بان
رسلت اللاجئين اؤيد ضيفك الكريم من
اسطنبول بانها مساله معقده لماذا لانه
هناك بعض الشرائح من اللاجئين ربما لا
تريد ان تعود لاسباب بالماء وهناك بعض
اللاجئين الذين يمكن ان يعودوا وهم همم
بين السماء والطارق لا حول لهم ولا قوه
وهناك بعض اللاجئين ايضا ربما يعتقد بانه
لو عاد لن يستطيع ان يبني مستقبلا هناك
مشاكل هذه ذات طابع له فيما يتعلق بالجمل
لا حول ولا قوه
التوفيق او من فقد كل شيء في داخل السوري
اليس همم من واجب النظام السوري ان يوفر
له اساليب الحياه المحترمه حتى يتمكن من
العوده فيما بعد
كل
هؤلاء لابد من النظر اليهم كشريحه خاصه في
اطار عودتهم لكي يكون هناك بنيه تحتيه على
الاقل قادرين ان يصلوا اليها قادرنا ان
يبداوا منها قادرين على ان يشعر بالثقه
والطمانينه والامان بعد ان يعود الى هذه
الارض لكن اعود واقول انها كل هذا الامر
هو لا ينجز الا بالتفاق سياسيا رسميا
وربما بسبب هذه التحولات الايجابيه في
الموقفين التركي والسوري تجاه بعض
يحل هذا الموضوع طيب هذا في نقطه لاجئين
في نقطه اكثر حساسيه دكتور بكير يقول
الباص وهي قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه همم
يبدو بان هناك زياره لوزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود شاويش اوغلو لا نعلم ان كان
اللقاء الثلاثي على مستوى وزاره الخارجيه
سيتم قبل زياره وزير الخارجيه التركي الى
واشنطن او بعد ذلك البعض عن نقطه استفهام
حول زيارته لواطن وكانه هناك
بات ستسبق الترتيبات فيما يخص قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه خاصه وان هذه القوات مدعومه
من واشنطن يقولوا البعض
فكيف هي العمليه كيف ستتم
السؤال الموجه الي عفوا الحذرتك دكتور
بكير نعم
طيب شكرا همم نعم
امس وصل همم
مسؤول امريكي يحمل رساله خاصه الى تركيا
او مقترحات
للحكومه التركيه
واليوم سلمت هذه المقترحات الى الحكومه
التركيه
واعتقد في همم في هذا المساء من الليل
المتاكد سوف يرجع هذا المسؤول الامريكي
الى الى الولايات المتحده همم
اللقاء التي سوف تجمع وزير الخارجيه
التركي ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي في 16 او
17 شهر من بعد ايام طبيعي سوف تكون من اهم
نقاطها هي تواجد قصب والدعم الامريكي لها
علما علما بانه هناك بساطات دول اخرى ل-
بين تركيا والولايات المتحده حول قسم
وهناك اقتراحات مباشره من طرف الولايات
المتحده حول قسمتهم ولكن استطيع ان اقول
من الان طبيعي هذه حسب بعض المعلومات بعض
المعلومات اريد ان ننوه ليست
اكيده هذه بعض المعلومات الى الان اا
التفاهم استطيع ان اقول شبه مستحيل
لا اقول مستحيل ولكن شبه مستحيل الى الان
لان الاقتراحات التي جاءت على لسان
الامريكيين وحتى كما يدعى على همم الرساله
التي وصلت اليوم او سلمت هذا اليوم هذه
اقتراحات همم
تركيا لا تثق بالولايات المتحده ابدا وهذه
الاقتراحات لن تؤخذ بجديه من الطرف التركي
مهما كانت مهمه او غير مهمه
دكتور بكير هل تثق في موسكو هل يمكن دي
موسكو ان تلعب دور ما شمال سوريا حتى
تحاول ان همم تجد حل لسوريا ولتركيا فما
يخص وجود الاكراد تعتقد
همم انا يعني اذا تسالين وموقفي واضح جدا
وقطع اعلنتها في قناه قنواتكم العربيه
والعربيه الحدث برارا وتكرارا الاثنين همم
هي يعني بالنسبه لتركيا همم
لا اقول فقط اعداء واكثر من اعداء لا اقول
اعداء اكثر من اعداء لان الاثنين يخططاني
همم خطا خبيثه لتركيا ان كانت في شمال
سوريا او في دول الجوار وهذه اللعبه
مكشوفه وهذه الالعاب مكشوفه من طرف تركيا
ومعروفه ولكن همم استطيع ان اقول شيء واحد
اذا نريد ان نعطي من 100 درجه انا اقول
للولايات المتحده 100 ولروسيا 99 يعني اقل
من 100 واحد فقط
هناك ازمه ثقه مع واشنطن ومع موسكو كذلك
فسؤال المطروح على ما تعول هل تعول على
وساطه روسيه همم
للتقارب مع سوريا يبدو الموضوع في القليل
من الحرج
ادعي لي اذا اعطيتيني دقيقتين اشير الى
هذه النقطه تركيا تريد تريد همم ان تكون
العلاقه مع سوريا جيده لماذا لانها هي
الضامن
همم المعارضه السوريه بشقيها العسكري
والسياسي وللشعب السوري الذي هم اكثر من
ثلاثه ونص مليون داخل الاراضي التركيه
واكثر من ثلاثه مليون على الحدود السوريه
التركيه يعني التركيه لا تستطيع ان تقول
نحن لا نستقبل الولايات المتحده ولا نستك
بروسيا ولا ناسك بسوريا ولكن همم الحوار
مغلق تماما انا قلت واحد في المئه بالنسبه
لنا هذه تعتبر كبيره جدا جدا لابد على
تركيا ان تستغلها ولذلك همم كانت هذه
الاقتراح التي جاءت على في طهران بين
الرئيس التركي والرئيس الايراني والرئيس
حول امكانيه ايجاد حل وافقت تركيا من حيث
المبدا وما زالت ولكن هذا لا يعني بانه
هناك ثقه لروسيا روسيا والولايات المتحده
ليست الان فقط منذ سنين متفقين على الملف
السوري وماذا طريقه يعني الطريقه التي سوف
يتعاملون بها وهم نعم نعم
محدوده يبدو بان هناك ثقه
ساختم في دقيقه معك
قد تتعمق بين الجانبين المعنيين بدرجه
اولى بهذا التقارب تركيا وسوريا وهل يمكن
العمل على شيء جدي مع وجود ازمه ثقه هذه
انا اعتقد بان
الاخلاقيا حديث ضيف جلكريم صحيح ولكن
اعتقد في الالعاب السياسيه وخاصه الان في
المسار السياسي الذي يدشن تحدثت المصالح
فاسقطت كثيرا من حسابات الاخلاق فيما
يتعلق بالسياسه ولا اخلاق في السياسه كما
يعرف الجميع وبالتالي الحين تتحدث المصالح
الان ازمه الثقه اساسا اذا اردت ان نقول
بين سوريا وامريكا لا توجد همم ثقه ولا
يبحث هذا الامر اليوم انا اعتقد ان
الجانبين السوري والتركي يبنيان عناصر ثقه
جديده بناء على همم ما قبل احد عشر عاما
التي مرت من الصدامي والجفاء والعداوه
واعتقد بان المصالح التي تحركت حتى من قبل
موسكو موسكو تتحرك باتجاهين باتجاه تركيا
لها مصالحها الحيويه والاستراتيجيه في
الاقليم وفي العالم وتعتقد وصلت الى مرحله
بسبب ازمتها في اوكرانيا ان البوابه
الروسيه هي الرئه التي يمكن ان تتنفس منها
لاحقا على المستويات الاقتص والسياسيه
وباتجاه دمشق موسكو الضائمه لكل شيء
والموجود عسكريه وسياسيا واقتصاديا في
سوريا تريد ان تقول ايضا للاطراف
الاقليميه والعامه الخارجيه لانها قادره
على تحويل ما قدمت عليه في العمل العسكري
الى ترجمه سياسيه وبالتالي انهاء اكثر
الملفات تعقيدا بين سوريا وبين الاخرى وهي
تركيه اليوم بنت هذه روسيا بنت هذه
القاعده واعتقد انها همم ان انقره تدير
علاقاتها مع موسكو في مهاره الابراج ماتيه
كما اا هو معروف عنها دائما
هذا اللقاء الثلاثي يقال بانه سيتم بين ال
14 والسادس عشر اذا همم ذهب وزير الخارجيه
التركيه لهذا اللقاء الثلاثي قبل اللقائه
همم وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا
لكم على المشاركه وعلى الحضور من دمشق عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي ومن اسطنبول
دكتور
شكرا لكم